we have a subreddit at david pakman.com
slash our EDD i.t nearly 10,000 now of
our viewers and listeners are regularly
participating in political and other
discussions and a few interesting
threads I noticed this morning that I
want to point out one is about a recent
poll about Joe Biden's likability
pointing out that a CNN poll that
resulted in the conclusion that Joe
Biden is very popular didn't poll
anybody between 18 and 49 and that is
absolutely true if you look at the
internals of the sample Joe Biden came
out extraordinarily popular without
including voters age I believe it was 18
to 49 maybe it was 24 to 49 now Joe
Biden is still popular if you look at
polls that do include people who are
under 50 years old but that is a concern
that's not very serious if you don't
have proper samples that include people
of all voting ages when you evaluate how
popular a candidate is so the bottom
line is Joe Biden's popularity may not
be as rock-solid as some polls suggests
although it's pretty clear the guy's is
pretty popular at this point also from
the david pakman show subreddit bado
O'Rourke's 6.1 million dollars in
fundraising on his first day came from
128 thousand donors averaging forty
seven dollars each that is interesting
because it is a much higher dollar per
donation per donor rate than for example
Bernie Sanders and immediately this is
leading to allegations that beta or
Rorick is the establishment big DNC
money candidate and that that may well
be true we will sort of soon I guess in
a little bit probably mid April or
something like that
have first-quarter FEC disclosures and
normally those are not the most exciting
documents but because of the questions
around the dynamics of who's donating to
Bernie who's donating to Beto or org and
in what quantities and with what
frequency I'm actually looking forward
to the first quarter
FEC filings from the 2020 Democratic
primary candidates more on that the
middle of next month
more than likely and lastly from the
david pakman show subreddit david should
start taking more international calls
until americans stopped using
speakerphone when calling in yet you
know here's the thing recently I took
like three or four international calls
during live calls and the connections
were just beautiful no speakerphone
crystal-clear audio
could hear even people who don't speak
English as a native language I could
understand them perfectly it's a small
sample size but the trend does not bode
well for our American callers that there
are so many people on speakerphone so
many people stomping roaches and doing
quote tool work as I mentioned last week
turing during the phone calls that i
will probably have to start giving
priority when we take phone calls to
numbers that pop up with country codes
that are outside of the united states I
wish this weren't the case but the
international callers really are putting
to shame the call quality of our of many
of the people in our American audience
make sure you subscribe for free to the
david pakman show subreddit at david
pakman.com slash re d di t nearly 10,000
of our viewers and listeners regularly
participating there and I'm there as
well if you have story suggestions guest
suggestions a great place to make them
is the subreddit one of today's sponsors
is privacy calm slash Pakman this is a
free service that I've actually been
using myself for a while now and I love
it
you just take a few seconds to link your
debit card or bank account to privacy
coms mobile app or browser extension for
Firefox and Chrome and what that does is
allow you to instantly create virtual
credit cards that are linked to your
bank account so that you're not actually
putting your real debit card number on
the Internet and you use these virtual
credit card numbers to buy things online
and with one click of a button you have
the ability
to create multiple virtual cards delete
cards freeze and unfreeze cards you can
put a limit on a card so a company won't
be able to charge you more than you
actually want them to and it protects
you from being hacked it protects you
from companies being hacked which we've
been talking about for a while on the
program and it's perfect for signing up
for free trial somewhere if you don't
want your real credit card number to be
exposed and on file and their app and
browser extension let you autofill the
virtual credit card number into the
credit card field when you're buying
things online there are a ton of
different advantages to shopping and
paying bills with a system like this
everything is totally secure and
encrypted and in some situations you can
earn 5% cash back on your purchases it's
all completely free all you have to do
is click the link under this video to
get started and for a limited time
everybody in our audience who signs up
gets $5 towards your first purchase when
you sign up using that link below